in this episode of XXfiles:
If we can gain a glimpse of what their health status is
just by taking a small piece
of skin and looking at these microbes
then that may aid our understanding of
their health and ultimately that's what
we need for their conservation.
Wooh! Humpback!
We have a humpback too.
Oh there's a couple up here.
Little dolphin.
Oh, here he is.
Wooh!
My name is Amy Apprill and i'm an assistant scientist
at the Woods Hole Oceanographic Institution.
I've been studying the skin microbiome
of the humpbacks for several years now.
And we started to pick apart some
trends in this microbiome.
A microbiome is basically just an assemblage
of microorganisms.
These are mostly single cells
that live in association with a marine animal.
We've been able to look at
several health compromised whales.
That either have been stranded on beaches
or entangled in fishing line and what
we found is that their microbiome is
shifted compared to the healthy animals.
And so they don't have these same what
we think are potentially helpful groups
of bacteria on their skin and these
health compromised animals also have started
to develop relationships with potential pathogens.
So if we can gain a glimpse
of what their health status is
just by taking a small piece of skin and
looking at these microbes then that may
aid our understanding of their health
and ultimately that's what we need for
their conservation.
We're going to look at the microbes
in two different ways
One way as we look at who the microbes
are using their DNA as well as look at
where the microbes are under the microscope.
It's been really exciting to bring this
new way of looking at the microbiome
to a community of marine mammal scientists
that are already so invested in learning
more about the health of these animals
and the measures that are needed to
conserve the species.
I'm working with Jooke Robbins who's a senior scientist
at the Provincetown Center for Coastal Studies.
Jooke's been fantastic and getting us skin samples
that we can take into my lab
and start to analyze and look at at the microbes.
Do you see him David?
No.
Ugh, that might have been a dive which means
we may not see him for a few minutes.
Yesterday we were out on the tip of Cape Cod
cod chasing humpback whales.
We were lucky enough to obtain a skin biopsy sample
from one of these humpback whales.
We then spend a little bit of time
cleaning up the samples and then we send
them off to a sequencing facility.
Usually within a couple weeks we receive our data back.
The sequence data that we get back  is just letters.
This is the DNA code.
In every sample that we've looked at
from basically around the world
we find two main groups of bacteria:
This is a really powerful finding.
That we find wales living in really different
ocean environments that have
the same types of bacteria on their skin.
And then whales do this other thing that
I think is really cool is that they shed
their skin pretty frequently and so
they're constantly somehow reviving that
population of microbes.
We think there must be some other type of mechanism
that allows these cells to maintain
residence on the skin surface.
The whale skin is so complex and that there are so
many cells there that it's really
challenging to pick apart what is a microbial cell.
So the way that we're going about that is
we're using a DNA strand that's specific for bacteria
and it has a fluorescent tag on the end.
And we add that to these little thin sections
and allow it to sit overnight
and then what we'll do is look at it
under the microscope and where we see
that fluorescent tag should correspond
to where the bacterial cells are.
Oh yeah there's the edge.  That's cool.
So here we're looking at the surface of the
skin layer and under the microscope we
see the structure of the the skin
in white here in contrast to the black
where there's no sample what we're
looking for some some bright spots where
probe and we do see a few of those on
the surface right in that area
yeah there's another chain cells over
there and potentially some deeper as well.
Once we look at more samples
we'll be able to form a better understanding
of how these cells are associating with the whale skin.
Oh my god look, it just surfaced.
Right over there.
So we've been following this juvenile humpback whale
for several minutes now.
Thus far we don't recognize it as a whale
that we've catalogued before
nor as a whale that we
biopsy sampled before and that's why it's
important for us to get a sample today
to apply to a number of different studies.
Jen is poised with a dart biopsy and
what Jen's is going to be doing here is
hopefully when the whale comes up to the
surface and the boat is at the right angle
and close enough to the animal
Jen is going to release that dart and
get a skin biopsy from from the whale
Alright.
Nice work Jen.
Let's take a sample.
The dart has a float that will let it remain
at the surface until we're able to pick it up with the net.
Being able to scale up
from this relationship that we're studying in the lab
to actually seeing these animals
in the wild is really important.
We're also interested in expanding our
studies to more species of marine mammals.
So we've studied about 16 species
thus far and there's about 129 species
of marine mammals out there.
We're finding new kinds of life everyday
and these microbiomes on marine mammals
haven't been studied in any capacity in the past.
So it's allowing us to discover a new relationship.
I can't believe how many new collaborations
I've been able to spin up
just in the last few years and so I
think this is a really good sign
and a promise that we're going to be able to
continue this research.
What does a trumpet sound like?
[Whale sounds]
Yeah, it's a blow but with more energy behind it and a bit of whine in it.
It's a little bit of tonal,
Not quite like an elephant.
Yeah.
[Whale sounds]
That's a trumpet.
Oh I heard that trumpet!
So it's been shown that dogs can
actually detect cancer what we're doing
is we're trying to use dogs to help us
determine what volatile biomarkers are
associated with ovarian cancer.